if you've played your share of Ubisoft
open-world games you know the deal
revealing the secrets and collectibles
of a given area outpost or district
takes a bit of effort it's a more
layered form of infiltration and
watchdogs hacking CTOs centers isn't
enough you also need to hack the various
CTOs towers within each part of Chicago
the challenge is in gaining access to
these fenced in towers these spatial
puzzles are some of the best brain
teasers in watchdogs but if you do find
yourself stumped here's a collection of
walkthrough videos to guide you to each
tower mad mile Northwest approaching
from the north head down a wide alley
leading to the courtyard while still on
the ground level look for an unlock
panel after hacking the panel had
further down the alley and used the lift
to your right climb until you reach the
roof then look for a small glass bridge
cross it but before you hop the fence
make a 180-degree turn to find another
unlocked animal now hop the fence go
through the CTOs gate and make a right
cross the glass bridge walk across the
roof and hop over the railing to reach
the tower
parker's square east this tower puzzle
serves as a reminder that forklifts and
other movable objects occasionally hide
cameras from view when you're within the
fence of the facility hack into the
first available camera then hack the
forklift to reveal another camera this
camera will give you a view of the
unlock panel for you to hack walk back
to the facility entrance and pass
through the CTOs gate climb up the
ladder then drop down to the area with
the forklift to access the tower
Parker Square South using the public
furniture sign as the starting points
head south and make a ride into the
first alley head into the small parking
lot with the barbed wire and forest wall
and climb up using the forklift keep
climbing until you reach the catwalk on
the right and use another lift as a
bridge to reach another part of the
building then climb up the two-tier
generator then the balcony and finally
the ladder
pack the camera next to the CTOs tower
and look to the right
hack the unlock panel to gain access to
the tower
the wards west this is the CTOs tower
closest to the El train tracks and yes
you'll need to cross the track in order
to reach the tower starting at ground
level look for the stairs surrounded by
a chain-link fence
slightly north west of the tower climb
up the stairs in the nearby ladder to
reach tracks
cross the tracks to reach the CTOs tower
hack the camera and look left to access
another camera now look left and down to
find a junction box pack the box to
create an explosion that will destroy
the nearby pallets turns out the pallets
obscured the unlock panel the wards east
start by hacking the camera next to the
billboard west of the tower then access
the camera in the middle of the facility
look right and hack the next camera
which will give you a view of the first
unlock panel after hacking the panel hop
on the nearby lift and raise it to reach
the facility climb up a couple of boxes
to reach the CTOs tower entrance after
passing the gate make a right and climb
up the large generator from there you
have a good view of the next unlock
panel to hack return to the chain-link
entrance and make a right progress along
the side of the building until you reach
a ladder climb up the ladder and move
forward until you see another CTOs
chain-link gate go through that to reach
the tower
Brandin docks West's our video starts on
the west side of the facility hack the
camera at the center of the building
then look slightly up and to the left to
hack another camera now you have a good
view of the unlock panel hack that and
then go through the door with the yellow
sign with the black hand exit the room
through the other door hop the fence to
your left and then use the lift follow
the only available path to reach the
tower
Brandon docks east starting at the
entrance of the facility look left to
find a small single story building in
the unlock panel around the corner if
you're stumped it could be because you
found the carrier too far for a
successful roof
so what else can fit in one of those
carriers simple use a nearby car to help
you jump far enough to reach the roof of
the tower
Brandon docks central start by heading
east from the tower toward a lift ride
the lifts climb the ladder on the right
and make another right to cross the
catwalk while facing the fenced gate
hacked the one visible camera this will
give you a view of the unlock panel but
you should hack pass through the gate
and look for the door with the yellow
sign with the black hand while facing
the door TURN RIGHT 90 degrees and hack
the camera look to the right and hack
the camera inside the warehouse office
this will give you a good view of the
next unlock panel hack it to gain access
to the tower the loop South using the
red tower icon in the mini-map as a
reference point go into the middle of
the block where the four alleys meet use
the nearby camera to jump to a second
camera closer to the tower this should
give you a good view of the unlock panel
now look to the left for another camera
to hack which will give you a clearer
view of a second unlock panel now climb
on the nearby lift and raise it then
climb up the generator and over the
adjacent railing run up the two sets of
steps and make a left to climb up
another level pass through the CTOs gate
and make another left to climb to an
even higher level when you get to the
top look left to find the tower the loop
north this Tower puzzle is another
reminder that if there's a scissor lift
nearby you'll most likely need to use it
when the lift is fully risen moves
straight ahead toward the climate
alleges keep climbing until you reach
the CTOs gate ignore the camera at the
corner of one of the fences and instead
pack the camera that's further in the
distance look to the right for the
unlock panel pack it then swing the
camera around so that two cameras are in
view hack the higher camera to get a
view of the second unlock
annal pack the panel pass through the
unlocked CTOs gate and make a right
after passing the second gate via right
and climb up the generators to reach the
tower the loop northeast begin by
heading into the alley south of the red
CTOs tower marker once you've gotten a
good glimpse of the tower look for a
catwalk and the camera that's nearly
above the catwalk pack it then hack the
second camera that's within the first
cameras view you'll now be able to spot
the unlock panel which you should hack
while you're in that view look straight
ahead and hack the lift in the distance
walk over to the lift and ride it all
the way to the top run through the two
CTOs gates and drop down one level to
reach the tower mad mile northeast a
good starting point is a block west of
the red CTOs tower icon on the mini-map
look for a set of abstract steps where
each step is slightly taller than 80
Perce climb those steps and continue
running forward past the generators and
over the railing use the metal awning to
cross to the next building climb up to
generators to reach another rooftop
continue moving forward and crossed the
two large adjoining metal awnings look
for the ventilation ducts and even more
generators climb those objects to reach
the CTOs gate then head north
dropping down one level and move along
the edge of the building until you reach
another set of events and generators
climb up and hop over the nearby plants
advance several paces to finally reach
the first unlock panel did you notice
the intrusion panel after reaching the
CTOs gate go back to that panel and hack
it using two interior cameras will
reveal the last unlock panel giving you
finally access to the tower mad mile
island it's best to start this puzzle on
the small pier next to the red tower
icon while facing the CTOs logo look up
and slightly to the left to find and
hack the first camera for the next
camera you should also look up in to the
left now you have a view of the unlock
panel
run toward the CTOs facility and go up
the stairs while facing the water make a
left and continue moving along the side
of the building until you reach the
ladder climb the ladder and look for
another unlock panel hack it to pass the
CTOs gate right in front of you proceed
forward to reach the tower
you